action
I know it takes a few seconds to get
everybody on but big shout out to
everybody on
purpose
go ahead what do you want Tick-Tock your
Tick Tock yes YouTube YouTube Instagram
insta Facebook Facebook big shout out to
everybody alive I'm going on live in
four different platforms right now
mainly because I've got 10 minutes and
I'm super excited uh Discord if you're
watching this I've got the Discord up
right now please put hashtag watching
live what are we talking about we're
talking about one of the Great Moments
of my professional career I just tweeted
this out I'm about to get a little
emotional I think I'll let you know when
I talk about my mom it gets me into a
weird place but this is true
um
when we came to America obviously we
didn't have a whole lot and my mom
reminded me when I was talking to her
about this collaboration dropping which
is for everybody watching because not
everybody knows what I'm about to say we
just announced that
the uh first drop of collectible plush
and collectible figurines are going to
be available this October November
December at Macy's across the U.S
physical stores with a Toys R Us inside
the Macy's if you didn't see the big
news several months ago was announced
that Toys R Us is coming back as a store
within a store inside Macy's we see this
in a lot of different retailers I'm sure
you've seen them around I'm super
excited about that ironically and this
kind of led me to this it's nice to make
content I made a video about Toys R Us
being an underpriced brand Somebody went
out and bought it did a really clever
thing and did storm for the store if
you're in Jersey The American Dream by
the stadium where my New York Jets play
have a huge Toys R Us in there it was
really cool check that out recently it's
but we announced that our toys are now
live my number one job is to expand the
intellectual property the stories the
demand how are you going to fall in love
with the common sense cow how are you
going to fall in love with the willful
wizard well it's not only having this
you know rocking on your shelf or in
your bed or playing with it but pretty
soon here mid-october these little uh
blow codes are going to send you to some
content so I'm on my journey like I've
said from day one of building one of the
most important Brands this is a huge
step of distribution many people will be
picking up these toys inside many people
are picking up these figurines and
collectibles inside of uh Toys R Us uh
at around the country that have never
heard
I'll be friends don't even know what an
nft is so I'm very excited about
expanding the this property and I ask
the team to go live and actually fire
away some questions on the
characteristics of practicality or
gratitude or being the bigger person
those are the six core figures that
we're putting out we're actually putting
out 10 figures because there's the Blind
Bags if any of you got kids go to
Claire's or Toys R Us or other places
you know the blind bags are big deal
there's 10 characters in that but six in
the court plush and figurine the genuine
giraffe the Practical peacock be the
bigger person Common Sense cow wolf of
wizard and gratitude gorilla I'm fired
up about this I really fired up about
this
[Music]
okay so just first thing that comes to
mind when you hear the word willful
willful winning all right
when you're welcome
remind me of Charlie sheet
okay uh next one common sense uh Common
Sense uh an underrated trait okay all
right you want to do it off the cuff
over it and underrated right now
oh I didn't finish I swear to them or
not no so we came to America
before and my mom dreamed of shopping
inside of DC
that was like
the Holy Grail like that you know that
was like my today's like Barneys like
like for us that was like for her it was
so expensive to go and buy a piece of
clothing or a handbag or something for
Macy's was like the Rolls Royce she
didn't even know about Paris fashion
week or something you know and so should
we just talk about how I can scene it is
for her you know like to go from a place
that like wanting to be able to buy one
thing
or one day to having the child that you
brought to in America creating a brand
that's sold inside those stores she's
like this is just so real so it's really
cool I'm really excited about this
collaboration and then for me and my
sister Toys R Us was the Macy's we one
day actually being able to buy something
at Toys R Us this is a very personal
collaboration for me and I'm excited
about it let's keep going yeah well I
think that plays into one of our
questions you've got gratitude gorilla
right here how does gratitude for you
play into your business dealings your
professional life
my professional life is very easy and
lacks anxiety and lacks pressure that I
see that most people carry with it
because I have so much gratitude of the
health and well-being of four to seven
to twelve people in my life that nothing
else matters and thus I'm able to really
navigate a high pressure career a public
Persona
that you know comes with tons of baggage
I opened up my Tick Tock this morning
and there's like a roasting of Me video
by a comedian and like unless you're
like very simply grateful
for what you have versus all the other
collateral garbage that comes along with
being a human being there's good and bad
but when you're fully grateful you're
able to navigate with speed and
confidence and happiness and
when I saw that video this morning for
example I'm grateful that I don't make
those kind of videos
I'm grateful and I'm happy I'm grateful
that I'm simple
a grateful period it is the number one
driver I believe deep down
that makes everything go for me I'm
really genuinely believe that gratitude
is the under and it's funny we talk
about a team off site yesterday and I
mentioned it for a half a second and we
moved on because we're about to go
around it remember when I said the
Gratitude stuff doesn't do as well
nobody wants to do this thing because
it's the best
nobody wants to be grateful for what
they have they want to put all their
energy on what they don't have what they
haven't accomplished yet what they're
missing what their friend got that they
didn't their friends have better parents
but a better City they they got lucky
everybody wants to put all that energy
and if you just are genuinely thankful
grateful for what you have everything
gets real easy real [ __ ] bad
attempts
that's truth okay
more word association talk to us about
practical what comes to mind when you
hear the word practical DJ
all right why
me and my sister have a nickname for AJ
we called rationalean
Jack he's just very practical like very
like
he's super to golf now and
she freaking the other days just like
right down the Fairway like he's just
he's just in his pocket so I'm a big fan
of practicality I talk about my
framework as practical optimism
like and it's funny I have a lot of
Instagrams and be friends like the
Practical you know peacock and the
optimistic otter
they're destined for the Tag Team
Championship
because practical optimism I think is
what I do I'm very optimistic which
helps them Drive had a great wine dinner
last night with a bunch of real winners
culture movers real
and um I was talking about something
that I'm concerned about that one of the
individuals asked me is could like look
at world we all know each other but we
were going deeper
yeah wine and everything gets deeper
right then he said are you optimistic
and it was funny because he was asking
me because he felt like I might be
pessimistic because I was being
practical thoughtful you know you can't
be delusional about what's going on with
the recession inflation things that
nature and so I laughed a little bit
because of how optimistic I am but there
is a level of massive practicality so I
think I do think of my brother for
playing word association but I I think I
share a lot of
okay and how do you think a big shout
out to Kung Fu DJ who just said in
Discord that they just picked up at
eight
figurines and plushies
[Laughter]
life just got one vital and one plush
and he lover to UK yes oh yeah is it
International yes
17. we need we're going to wrap it up
here in a second okay yeah gotta go
Aiden got seven all right we gotta go
we're gonna do more lives I miss all of
you hope you're good uh go to the
Discord it's linked in my Instagram I
just tweeted it I don't know if it's on
the other platforms but it's definitely
on my Instagram right now or definitely
if that's not working because some
people have trouble with that if you go
to Twitter I just tweeted out in the
last couple of minutes there's probably
a bunch about the toys but one of the
last seven to ten tweets is a direct
link to the Discord it's also
garyvee.com Discord
Discord if you're watching come into the
Discord learn learn about web free
branding IP but it's just
please join us if you're watching right
now this uh gallery.com
Discord
garyvee.com Discord if you're joining
right now for the first time in the chat
please say first time from your live
right now literally putting here first
time from your live and um I'm excited
about it check out macys.com they've got
toys up now for pre-order plus I'll be
live physically in Chicago in New York
there's a blog post in announcements and
Discord and other places to be friends
Twitter account for all the details
can't wait to see you love you see ya
system